some of the things you have done that  brought you to the elie wiesel  foundation I think it's a mate growing  up I had two heroes my parents  generation was talking about different  ones but my two heroes as a child were  and continue to be elie wiesel and  Nelson Mandela and I saw two people who  were giving voice to people who needed  to be heard fighting injustice  intolerance in a very brave way and  actually making a difference that  inspired me as a young person and I  thought I had no ability Who am I not  too much money no connections but it  didn't stop me and I always wanted to  intervene where I could and very little  local things that became a part of life  and I've been blessed to have the  opportunity to do it now larger and  larger ways